Earlier I mentioned
the number field sieve, which is the best
factoring algorithm we have in terms of the way its cost scales.
In fact, the cost of this algorithm isn't actually rigorously proven because it's connected with some open questions about number theory,
but it is conjectured to have
a cost that looks like this.
This time the big-O is in the exponent, but I'm gonna sweep that
detail under the rug.
The key takeaway is that it's significantly better
than trial division because although N does
appear in the exponent,
it's raised to the power 1/3 and that translates to a much lower cost and that's why this algorithm
can handle numbers like RSA250, whereas trial division
most certainly can't.
It's still exponential though in the sense that a power of N is appearing in an exponent, and so, as a result,
it still can't handle
numbers like RSA1024.
Now let me say a little bit more about polynomial cost
versus exponential cost.
We say that an algorithm
has polynomial cost if its cost is big-O of N to the power B,
where B can be any positive number, but the key is that B has to be fixed, meaning that it doesn't change
as the input length end grows.
For the examples we saw a moment ago, meaning integer addition, multiplication, division, computing GCDs
and modular exponentiation,
we had that B was either
one, two or three.
So these are all
polynomial cost algorithms.
But when we say polynomial
cost more generally, B could be any positive number.
It could even be one million,
but it has to be fixed.
As a very rough abstraction, algorithms having polynomial
cost are typically viewed as representing efficient algorithms.
It's definitely an oversimplification, but as a rough guideline, you can think about a
polynomial cost algorithm
as somehow making use
of a problem's structure to construct a solution as opposed to a brute
force type of approach
or an exhaustive search
over a very large space.
Of course, an algorithm whose cost scales as N to the one million
on inputs of length N
would not reasonably
be viewed as efficient, and we wouldn't expect to be
able to run it on large inputs.
But still even an N to
the one million algorithm must be doing something clever that somehow reflects the structure
of whatever problem it solves to avoid the exponential scaling in cost that would be associated with
an exhaustive search over a large domain.
And in practice, the identification of a polynomial cost algorithm is really just a first
step towards efficiency.
If a problem is important
and someone discovers the very first polynomial
cost algorithm for it, maybe having a very large exponent,
you can be reasonably sure that algorithm designers
will find improvements that cause that exponent to come down.
In essence, you can
think about the existence of a polynomial cost
algorithm for a problem as demonstrating the feasibility
of solving that problem
on reasonably large inputs, but there still could be a lot of work required to reach true efficiency.
In complexity theory, it's typical to say that an algorithm's cost
scales sub-exponentially if the cost is big-O of two to the power N
to the power epsilon for every positive real number epsilon, and if it's not sub-exponential,
then it's exponential, or it could even be super-exponential like two to the two to the N,
which is doubly exponential,
but as long as the output
isn't super-exponentially long, every problem can actually be
computed by a Boolean circuit
having exponential cost as it turns out. So the important distinction here is between polynomial
and exponential cost.
We don't know of any sub-exponential cost classical algorithms for
integer factorization.
For example, the number field sieve's cost is not big-O of two to
the N to the epsilon when epsilon is 1/3 or less,
so it doesn't satisfy this definition.
It's undoubtedly a very clever algorithm, but it's still a sieve and we're still effectively searching
over a very large space to identify factors of a given number.
As we'll see in the next lesson, there is in fact a polynomial
cost quantum algorithm for integer factorization.
Shor's algorithm has polynomial cost and specifically it has qubit cost, similar to modular exponentiation.
Another class of problems that
you might be familiar with is the class of NP-complete problems.
I won't go into what NP-complete problems are in this lesson, but you can look them
up if you're interested.
It's conjectured that
none of these problems have sub-exponential cost.
That's essentially a circuit-based version of what's sometimes called the
exponential time hypothesis, but so far nobody's been able
to figure out how to prove it.
In fact, we can't even prove that there aren't linear cost algorithms for NP-complete problems.
It's just really tough, at
least as far as we know, to rule out the possibility
of a future discovery of an incredibly creative
algorithm for these problems.